the best piece of advice I got comedic
ly as a stand-up was from an acting
coach mmm and I studied in Lee Strasberg
theatre Institute in LA and some of the
some of the intense you know acting
schools
my dad was an actor studio guy and so I
was studying with a teacher named laelia
Goldoni she was unbelievable because she
never let me get away with my [ __ ]
tricks you know because those are my
defense mechanism trying to hide the
fact that I feel vulnerable and put up
this defense mechanism like I'm you know
uh you know my humor I'm in control and
teaching me that I am perfect and all my
flaws so show your flaws no no problem
with that because people now connect to
you she is secondly when I did five
minutes for her in front of the class
the jokes mechanically were sound I know
they were good jokes they laughed I got
laughs I was like ha showed her she sat
there with her arms folded her legs
crossed and she said oh look Jerry
thinks his jokes are so funny he doesn't
need to perform them and I said what do
you mean by that and she said I don't
know how you feel about any of that so I
don't care humans connect through
emotion Jerry go back home I want you to
write down how you feel about and play
the emotion make sure it's authentic
through each of these lines connect it
to the environment connected to the
pictures in fact don't even think of the
emotion think about the colors and the
textures and the sounds and the smells
of the events you're talking about
automatically the emotions will come to
you and so I practiced what she said by
at the same time rolling my eyes mm-hmm
I'll show her right I go back and I said
I'm just say my dad always said any time
an acting teacher gives you a note don't
ever take offense to it they're not
saying it because they dislike you
they're saying because they want to help
you and that gave me a whole different
perspective so somebody gives me a note
I never say oh [ __ ] you I'm like what do
you mean by that always follow up with a
question or two it'll help you to
clarify what they mean so I came back
and
delivered it the way she said and holy
[ __ ] what a difference applause breaks
on jokes that I just thought were funny
but Elson people oh my god and what you
said exactly happened to me my brother
does the same thing or my father you
know it's like the same thing and I was
like now what you were affecting people
you're not just making them laugh yes
they were leaving with an impact how did
you how did you inject that emotion you
said you'd think about the smells and
since well sir that's one of the lessons
in acting instead of just trying to play
sad
that's so general sad what do you mean
sad distraught you know upset
what good but if you remember the smells
textures and the scene about where that
emotion is connecting to that's when the
emotion comes out okay so you're not
just playing the label of an emotion
you're playing an experience so it
changes the way you play the experience
it's like when when I coach actors
sometimes on self tapes and a lot of
times they're they deliver the lines
looking at the character all the time
watch real actors they'll look at the
character maybe 20% of the time
especially if they're talking about an
event the event we go somewhere in our
eyes to the event in our memory and then
we check in with them once in a while so
if you're really remembering an event or
substituting a real event in your life
for that character you're gonna that
emotions gonna come to you hmm
and as comedians we get good at this
because we do it every night expressing
herself over a certain subject or
emotion or something if we can play
sarcasm we can play we can play
retaliation benign retaliation is
another structure very important
structure probably a great structure to
open with okay because I call it the
perfect joke form because it's got an
antagonist and a protagonist built in so
you can say that like when people say
hey you're a comedian tell me a joke I
always tell them a joke because if I
just say oh don't do jokes they do
stories what are the odds of them coming
to any of my shows zero but if I give
them a joke that was
where are you playing here there's an
app on my phone I opened it up it's a
form they put in their email they had
send with their first name they had send
it goes they automatically get an email
response that leads them to a two or
three minute video here's a clip you
know enjoy I'll send them something else
I just use I used MailChimp
MailChimp oh yeah I create a link on I
have it on my Evernote I just hit that
and it opens up the website with that
form on it and they put it in and I say
I'll invite you to a show it it's my fan
list yeah think this happens all the
time oh you're a comedian well tell me a
joke and I'll tell him a joke the joke
is usually my ex who cheated on me
called me on Halloween she's like Jerry
I don't know what to pretend to be for
Halloween I said why don't you just just
normally and pretend you're in a
committed relationship
that's funny were you playing right and
it's that simple you know and it's
rather than oh no do jokes or do stories
the reason we most of us say this
because we're not prepared yeah to say a
joke why not you know how many people
have come to see me based on that you
know probably hundreds you know based on
meeting people and asking to be on that
list you know by saying hey tell me a
joke you know so I just rambled no you
didn't know that was all relevant hmm so
with that was there anything else with
injecting emotion you go to the place
where you bring in a parallel experience
to find the emotion within a story don't
chase the emotion don't sort of let it
come to you okay just say you know oh my
god let me tell you about this my my ex
she's like just she's a plus plus you
know that's the that's the positive way
I tell my kids you know she's [ __ ]
nuts is what she doesn't but she's all
I'm doing is I'm picturing her picturing
in those situations how does she make me
feel sometimes she gets me so [ __ ]
frustrated and I just not afraid to
share that with the audience that does
take practice and that comes with
learning to be yourself the way you are
with your friends at a bar on that stage
because we tend to I want to put on my
best self on the stage rather than I
want to be completely vulnerable and be
the same guy I am at the bar on the
stage and that's why I tell the audience
time but like I'm so flawed you know I
got baggage I got Samsonite
you know but I'm not afraid because
that's made me who I am mm-hmm and being
able to be that way and be honest with
them on the stage now you're
communicating with them you know like it
though we're watching the world series
of comedy a lot of comics good jokes but
I don't feel the connection
I don't feel them connecting with the
audience at all you know there's they
want to get up there and recite their
jokes because they have a time limit
yeah you know and it's like be with us
it doesn't matter the amount of Lapp
point you get if you're with us there's
nothing on there that says how many
jokes did you do per minute on that on
the judging application or the form
it's like originality stage presence
overall performance those are the three
criteria but yeah laughs per minute do
matter but are you really still
connecting with us and communicating
with us but I've been doing this nine
and a half years and I'm just now
starting to kind of open up that level
of comedy and stuff just now like
peeling back that layer of like oh the
personal and what's finding the
emotional connection behind it so it's
like I've been on stage a lot and I'm
just now getting around to oh yeah
motion is important and you know I
should tell my story and tell jokes that
only I could say and I try to put my
jokes through a filter now of like what
can I do that someone couldn't steal
really mm-hmm hey hot brethren and
sistren thanks a lot for watching this
video if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips